ce phénomène cyclique commence quand les
eaux chaudes de l'océan pacifique
occidental tropicale se déplace vers
l'est le long de l'équateur en direction
des côtes d'amérique du sud
les eaux de surface chaudes du pacifique
reste alors près des côtes
[Musique]
l'augmentation de ces températures dans
l'est du bassin pacifique décale
l'activité des pluies dans l'est du
bassin donc donne des anomalies pluie et
peut donner des événements très pluvieux
accompagné d'inondations 20 sur la côte
est de l'amérique du sud
[Musique]
début janvier à asuncion les crues ont
contraint plus de 150000 personnes à
abandonner leur foyer
à différents endroits la capitale a
connu de graves inondations depuis le
mois de novembre à la mi décembre
le niveau du fleuve paraguay avait déjà
atteint six mètres 50
son plus haut niveau de toute l'année
largement supérieur au seuil déjà
critique de 5 mètres 50
beaucoup redoutaient le pire
des milliers de personnes ont été
évacuées des quartiers situés le long de
la rivière quand le niveau du fleuve a
atteint les 7 mètres 84 le 7 janvier
avec espace chaque fois la crue est plus
intense
c'est un lieu où le feu grandit sans
cesse était son loiret et dernièrement
il est devenu incontrôlable en décembre
je n'ai pas pu venir jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un effort pour
venir
mais mon père voyez ce n'est pas facile
d'accès
mon père a toute sa vie ici ces animaux
sa famille il ne veut pas partir
près de 6000 familles ont été touchées
dans les premières semaines de décembre
après que le niveau du fleuve a franchi
la barre des 7 m le nombre des victimes
a doublé treize mille familles furent
victimes des inondations la plupart
d'entre elles originaire de los banias à
dos le quartier pauvre de la ville situé
tout proche du fleuve
[Musique]
le gouvernement paraguayen déclara
l'état d'urgence à asuncion ainsi que
dans sept autres régions du pays
pareillement affectés
le phénomène el niño se produit de
manière aléatoire à peu près tous les
deux à sept ans et dure de 12 à 18 mois
engendrant des risques répéter
d'inondations dans les zones exposées et
la menace d'épidémie de choléra et de
paludisme
l'eau n'est pas allé jusqu'à la maison
elle est d'abord monté petit à petit et
puis c'est venu d'un coup ça s'est passé
comme ça en 74 ou 75
cette année nous allons et ayons des
deux fois l'eau est montée jusqu'au mur
la marque est arrivé quasiment à 9 m
nous sommes prêts à rester parce que
j'aime ma vie ici
le problème c'est la salle de bain la
lumière et les maladies
pas moins de 200 pylônes électriques ont
été détruits par les plus torrentielles
laissant des milliers de foyers sans
électricité
quatre personnes ont trouvé la mort
victimes de chutes d'arbres dans ce qui
fut considéré comme les pires
inondations depuis un demi siècle
[Musique]
le montant total des dégâts est estimé à
3,5 millions de dollars
[Musique]